deux camps d'humain s'affrontent les uns
repoussent la limite de la technologie
pour exploiter la nature les autres
disent qu'ils sont la nature et veulent
mettre les connaissances au service
d'une société plus juste les uns veulent
continuer comme avant les autres
résistent la lutte est inégale car ce
qui veulent un autre monde sont obligés
de vivre dans celui qu'il dénonce j'en
sais quelque chose mes parents avaient
décidé que leur fille aurait les mêmes
droits que les hommes ils disaient
qu'une société où les femmes n'étaient
pas les égal des hommes seraient
toujours bancales
pour eux l'argent n'avait pas tellement
d'importance qui comptait c'était les
connaissances alors mon père s'y réservé
est devenu un véritable activiste pour
ouvrir à sa fille les portes d'écoles
encore fermées aux femmes alors par
amour pour tes PARENTS tu t'es retrouvé
résistante au cœur du système éducatif
des hommes ah mais moi j'étais d'accord
pour résister contre une société
boiteuse mais j'avais la rage la rage
des temps fermé entre les murs de ses
écoles depuis toute petite je passais
mon temps à vagabonder dans un pays
imaginaire que j'appelais les steppes de
l'Asie centrale je ne savais pas ce qui
était une step je ne savais pas où était
l'Asie centrale mais c'était un pays
d'une beauté inouïe parsemée de montagne
où les gens vivaient ensemble de façon
très simple et cuisinait sur des petits
feux de bois
moi c'est mon grand-père rescapé du
génocide arménien qui décortiquait mes
bulletins scolaires il me répétait sans
cesse que dans la vie il faut se hisser
toujours plus haut
ses rêves par procuration non oui mais
l'enfant des plaines du Berry s'est mise
à rêver de montagne je lisais en boucle
victoire sur la concagua le plus haut
sommet des Andes alors liberté
grands espaces des mesures conquêtes
héroïques tout me fascinent comme si
j'avais trouvé là le petit grain de
folie pour résister à une vie toute
tracée nous y sommes allés à la congagua
le camp de base était une vraie ville
c'était ça mon rêve
bah moi j'ai adoré le décor presque à la
hauteur de celui de mes steppes
leur Mandana chevauchants au vent tu
parles que le monde de macho ouais mais
souviens-toi de retour du sommeil ils
m'ont salué chapeau bas c'est vrai mais
si une femme doit gravir la concagua
pour être respectée la société n'a pas
fini de boiter pas tout à fait faux
année après année nous en avons consommé
du voyage en courant après le temps nous
sommes allés sur les montagnes aux
quatre coins du monde à la recherche de
je ne sais quoi
revenir au pied de l'Everest 20 ans
après notre première expédition nous a
ouvert les yeux cette foule et ces
panneaux Lodge interdite au porteur
toilettes interdite au porteurs un
véritable apartheid affiché au grand
jour nous pouvions plus rester dans ce
jeu de colonisation ah oui mais nous
avions quand même soif de découverte un
sacré Diem comment voyager sont détruire
ce qui nous attire nous avions juste
l'intuition que la lenteur était
indispensable et oui mais nos semaines
de congés n'étaient pas à rallonge
c'était pourtant simple pour avoir plus
de temps il suffisait d'arrêter de
travailler alors ça c'était une bonne
idée arrêtez de travailler retrouver la
liberté cette idée ne vous a-t-elle
jamais traversé l'esprit
mais bon soyons honnêtes quand même
cette liberté nous l'avions gagné en
travaillant et en nous passant au
maximum du superflu
bon c'était facile pour toi l'anti-âge
tous compulsif qui répète inlassablement
qu'acheter ce privé de liberté bon quoi
qu'il en soit là nous avons franchi une
sacrée limite bon sans cette liberté
nous ne serions jamais partis pour deux
mois explorer l'ouest du Népal c'était
en mars 2020 ou doutez un peu de la
suite non
quelques jours après notre départ le
gouvernement n'est pas allé à confiné
strictement
le destin a voulu que nous soyons à
quelques heures de marche du village de
Man Badour Kessi notre ami qui nous
guidait sur cette terre natale sans
hésiter ils nous emmener chez ses
parents sans hésiter ils nous ont ouvert
les bras ils ont décidé qu'il serait
notre grande sœur et notre grand frère
notre Didier notre Dadou c'est comme si
nous avions toujours fait partie de leur
famille ils nous ont assuré que nous ne
manquerions jamais de rien mais vous
savez là-bas ils n'ont rien on vit à
même le sol et on cuisine sur deux
petits feux de bois ce qu'on a cultivé
alors qu'avait-il à nous offrir
une maison tout simplement à toi rien
que pour nous nous avons fait revivre la
maison abandonnée ou man avait passé son
enfance cette maison était pour nous
synonyme d'indépendance c'était le plus
beau des cadeaux ah non il y avait
encore un plus beau cadeau parce qu'en
nous disant que nous ne manquerions de
rien Didier et dazou se portaient garant
de notre survie en milieu hostile en
fait ils devenait nos anges gardiens
immédiatement les élus locaux ont fait
nous leur réfugiés sanitaire réfugiés
sanitaire au fin fond du Népal dans le
plus beau de mes rêves moi j'aurais
jamais pu l'imaginer leur responsable de
la municipalité est venue en personne à
pied nous offrir un sac de riz et un sac
de lentilles il nous a donné accès à
Internet pour renouer le lien avec nos
proches et cerise sur le gâteau en plein
confinement il nous a accordé le luxe de
pouvoir circuler librement sur son
territoire
imaginez seulement c'était grand comme
la Gruyère
sur ce territoire c'est la bienveillance
qui règne la bienveillance entre
générations entre voisins et même avec
les inconnus en fait nous étions
entourés d'ange gardien cette fois tu es
tenais des steppe de l'Asie centrale ah
oui un vrai rêve éveillé en plus j'étais
libre de vagabonder dans les montagnes
mais attention
il n'était pas question uniquement entre
deux travaux agricoles un impensable
pour nous de ne pas prendre notre charge
de travail et en plus franchement c'est
un grand plaisir alors nous avons semé
repiquer récolté le blé le maïs le riz
et même le mille Didier dazou nous
aurait appris des gestes que nos
grands-parents maîtrisaient les travaux
étaient collectifs pas de bruit de
moteur l'ambiance était toujours joyeuse
et la fin des travaux était toujours
l'occasion d'une grande fête
et tu te souviens du jour Didier et
dazou
nous a dit rame rocam joli travail quand
il a vu que nous avions réussi à empiler
toutes les germes de paille dans le
grenier de la maison des Buffalo si bas
de plafond où il régnait une chaleur
d'enfer
de nous alors ça c'était une sacrée
récompense tu te souviens aussi du
repiquage de riz non non pas du tout les
rôles peuvent enfoncer leur plan à toute
vitesse en reculant et toi tu t'es vite
retrouvé seul à l'autre bout de la
rivière j'ai déclenché un fou rire
général
elle fumier sans rien dire pendant que
Didier dazou faisait leur sieste nous
sommes allés étaler à la main sous un
soleil de plomb tout le fumier sur le
grand champ les voisins étaient
stupéfaits ils se sont assis sur le
talus pour nous regarder faire ça a
signé notre adoption définitive par tout
le village et puis il y a eu le charmio
c'était un joli petit trèfle qui sentait
bon le citron mais il envahissait tout
le maïs et dévorait notre fumier tu as
alerté un ami chercheur qui a
immédiatement mis en oeuvre une chaîne
humaine de connaissances d'azo était
émerveillé des chercheurs à l'autre bout
du monde se mobilisaient gratuitement
pour l'aider à résoudre son problème il
adorait la phrase élargir les
connaissances pour les mettre au service
de la société
et d'ailleurs c'était aussi la phrase
fétiche de ton père celle pour laquelle
il y avait toujours voulu que tu sois
chercheuse pas faux au début des
vagabondages quand à chaque maison on
disait mais Bosnie assieds-toi moi je me
disais mais pour qui me prenne je suis
pas fatigué jusqu'à ce que je comprenne
combien passer du temps ensemble était
essentiel
moi aussi je râlais souvent ça m'arrive
tout le temps en descendant des bureaux
de la municipalité rurale
je suis encore monté pour rien il y
avait pas d'électricité ils ne m'ont
rien dit alors qu'il savait que ça
allait durer toute la journée
ouais j'ai fini par adorer ces coupures
d'électricité prétexte à d'interminable
discussion avec le responsable
informatique que tout le monde appelait
respectueusement itisseur
en philosophe sur les travers du monde
capitaliste et sur le sort des femmes il
leur prêchait de ne pas se marier trop
jeune et surtout de ne pas avoir trop
d'enfants
vous savez parfois jusqu'à
quel vin
d'un travail agricole Didi Venet me
disait allez viens on va fumer une
Soulle pas tous ensemble moi enfin
Didier on a presque fini on finit après
on fumera tranquillement Didier était
abasourdi par ma réaction
c'est normal là-bas travailler fait
partie de la vie le rapport au temps est
différent d'une autre on perd jamais son
temps et on ne cherche jamais à en
gagner moi je pense que là-bas ils n'ont
pas oublié que nous sommes juste sur
terre pour nous agiter quelques secondes
avant de mourir
tu sais finalement notre bonheur ne se
trouvait pas sur la voie de la réussite
professionnelle tracée par nos parents
oui mais en nous poussant par amour à
nos limites ils nous ont aidé à trouver
notre propre chemin puis comment
aurait-il pu deviner que notre bonheur
puisse être caché dans un petit village
perdu au fond des montagnes du Népal que
de chemin parcouru pour arriver à ce
bonheur tout simple tous les matins
l'oiseau du paradis nous réveillait ah
nous nous sentions heureux libre vivant
nous étions débarrassés du superflu et
entouré de personnes remplies de sagesse
et chaleureuse Didier Zazou ont toujours
refusé le moindre dédommagement
financiers il disait avec colère païssa
China pas d'argent les mots de Zazou
raisonnent encore en nous l'argent
pourri les liens humains
c'est plus facile d'en prendre
conscience quand tu es obligé de faire
un pas de côté quoi ça c'est pas faux
sept mois après notre arrivée nous
n'étions plus de simples étrangers de
passage tout le monde se comportait
comme comme si nous étions là depuis
toujours et pour toujours
la reprise des vols internationaux a été
un choc brutal
une note des services de l'immigration
un petit bout de papier faisait de nous
des clandestins on nous donnait l'ordre
de partir la frénésie de la société de
consommation nous avait rattrapé malgré
nous 7 jours d'acharnement pour réussir
à réserver deux places sur un vol
impossible de payer le code de sécurité
est envoyé sur un téléphone que nous
avions laissé en France
à moi j'y voyais un signe du destin nous
étions faits pour rester au paradis
et puis je t'ai interdit de solliciter
de nos amis
je ne l'ai pas écouté j'ai écrit à nos
amis et instantanément les plus matinaux
ont proposé de payer nos billets
des larmes se sont mises à couler sur
mon visage les amis n'est pas là ne
comprenaient pas ce qui m'arrivait ils
essayaient de me réconforter et leur
gentillesse m'a fait en fait je venais
de réaliser que nous allions devoir les
quitter moi je redoutais tellement ce
moment tous les matins je me disais un
jour de gagner au paradis mais en fait
nos cœurs étaient déchirés en deux d'un
côté la joie de revoir notre famille nos
amis et puis de l'autre côté le
désespoir qui était notre famille
adoptive et de refermer une parenthèse
de vie si simple si heureuse
de retour dans les Aravis nous avons
retrouvé toutes nos montagnes menacées
par de nouveaux projets d'aménagement
c'était comme les si les investisseurs
voulaient rattraper le temps perdu quand
les promoteurs immobiliers exigent de la
neige pas de problème
on remplit une demande de destruction
d'espèces protégées on sort les
tronçonneuses pour abattre une forêt les
pelleteuses creusent une bassine géante
pour y faire croupir de l'eau potable
ils appellent ça une retenue colinéaire
un projet de tel retenu colinéaire est
devenu en deux ans dans les Aravis le
symbole de la lutte entre deux mondes
que tout oppose celui qui veut continuer
à faire comme si de rien n'était et
celui qui essaie de limiter les dégâts
nous avions toujours espéré ne pas avoir
à choisir un camp mais là l'urgence on a
décidé autrement
nous avons choisi nous y avons trouvé
des rebelles
bienveillants chaleureux respectueux en
fait ils sont à l'image de notre famine
n'est pas l'aise mais le problème c'est
qu'ici ces personnes sont considérées
comme de très très dangereux individus
en juin dernier c'est citoyennes et
citoyens pacifiques ont voulu exercer
leur droit de manifester en randonnant
ils se sont retrouvés face à un
déploiement surréaliste de force de
l'ordre
propagande auprès de la population
locale contrôle d'identité fichage
fouille complète des véhicules fouille
des sacs à dos
saisis de dangereuses fourchettes en
bois de gourdes et même de couteau
suisse
est-il encore possible à l'heure
actuelle de faire entendre l'idée qu'une
autre société est envisageable et
pourtant quelques jours plus tard les
trois principaux fournisseurs d'énergie
française déclaraient que la meilleure
énergie est celle que l'on ne consomme
pas vous imaginez des opérateurs du CAC
40 qui vous demande de ne pas consommer
ce qu'il vendent une vraie révolution
et si cette pénurie annonçait d'énergie
était comme une occasion providentielle
pour faire un tout petit peu de tri dans
nos vies de nous demander ce que nous
voulons vraiment nous avons dépassé bien
bien des limites pour nous retrouver ce
soir devant vous afin de témoigner que
sortir de la surconsommation et non
seulement possible mais sources de
bonheur
alors pourquoi ne pas nous inspirer
Didier dazzou de leur bienveillance de
leur sagesse pourquoi ne pas les prendre
en exemple pour tracer la voie vers une
société sobre plus juste plus solidaire
avec amour et rage et poésie